hey what's up guys my name is achernar
welcome to episode 5 of game programming
ok so today we're gonna actually do
something really cool well actually
we're sort of not like we're gonna
explain some really cool stuff for when
I are actually gonna be able to get
anything onto our screen really cool
just yet just because I want to make
sure that you guys understand everything
so what we're gonna do today is actually
talk about buffer strategies or
particularly you know graphical um
buffering data buffering so at the
moment we've got this window that we
created last time and all it is at the
moment is just if I Ronon you'll see um
it is just just a window with you know
running being printed over and over
again in the console so we'll just
delete this line of code because that
was just for testing purposes basically
what's gonna happen is while the games
running it's gonna serve to to sort of
parts of um of code is gonna be repeated
over and over again and essentially you
can divide games into into two parts
right one is like the logic of the game
so in other words you know stuff like
calculations on to where you move
acceptance of like keyboard input events
or Mouse events are in our processing
way you shoot towards you know handling
stuff like multiplier stuff for example
like sockets and um
networking anyway list goes on there's
that part and then there's also the part
of actually rendering images to the
screen so in other words putting putting
you know drawing the player onto the
screen and the environment onto the
screen so there's like a graphical part
and then there's like a logic part now
the reason that there's two different
parts and we don't dump everything into
say the rendering part like why can't we
just say you know something like
something like I don't know do game for
example why can't we why can't we make a
method called do game and that'll handle
the rendering and like the logic stuff
all in one now the reason we actually
cannot do that is because of timing
issues everyone has a different computer
right now and if I make a game for you
guys and give it to you and tell you you
know open up fraps and tell me what FPS
you get tell me what frames per second
you get on that game like tell me how
your computer handles that game how that
game performs on your computer you will
all give me different numbers guaranteed
every single one of you will give me a
different minimum average and high on
the F on on an FPS benchmark and the
reason for that is all of you guys have
different configurations one of you
might have a supercomputer which runs
this game at 1,000 frames per second and
someone else might have a laptop or a
netbook which is running in at 20 frames
per second now the problem with that is
like literally that
how games work if you see the number
1,000 frames per second what it's doing
is it's actually you know completing all
the code in the game 1,000 times every
second it's calculating everything 1,000
times a second so in other words if we
tell it okay let's move the player at a
rate of one pixel per frame
then we're gonna be moving one pixel per
frame but not per second because
remember one pixel per frame that frame
the amount of frames that your computer
fits into one seconds into one second
depends on the speed of your computer on
the performance of your computer on this
game so in other words to simplify this
down a people who might not understand
what I'm saying is people with faster
computers will essentially run the game
faster meaning that their character will
move faster people will slower computers
their character will move slower
obviously that is unacceptable and we
need to normalize this so that we
actually move at so that the player
moves at the same rate no matter what is
playing on no matter if he's having 100
frames per second or or 1000 frames per
second the player obviously should still
move at the same speed so the handle is
we actually need a timer now we're not
gonna go over this now but essentially
we need one part of code which actually
handles things like player movement like
logic like Kay and mouse input events
control input events all that stuff the
logical stuff the stuff that gets
calculated and actually works out how
much you know animation for example how
much something moves that's just one
example of it as well as tons of stuff
related to that and then we need one
part of the game which actually is
unrestricted 1000 for a second and that
handles a rendering so in other words we
split this up into two different methods
one is called update and this update
method sometimes it's referred to as
tick okay tick and update it depends on
how you want to call it a lot of game
programmers not just not call um call
their methods tick instead of update
that's quite a convention I prefer to
call it update personally I've sort of
mediated over the years um I called a
tick for a while just because tick was
shorter and sort of you know you you
could say ticks and stuff like that and
it would work more than um updated but
I've sort of gone more mainstream I'm
gonna update now and then there's the
render method so there's a two methods
the worry about
to create called update and render now
the update method is going to handle all
the logic it's basically going to update
our game and the render is going to
actually display images to our screen
now update we will restrict to running
60 times per second in the future and
render will be unlimited so in other
words as we'll be rendering as fast as
we can but updating not as fast as we
can we'll be updating at a specific
speed too to ensure consistency
throughout computers
[Applause]
all right so we'll create these two
methods now simply by typing public
avoid the bo-peep they'll both be void
public void update that'll be the update
method which we're not going to talk
about today or do anything to you can
see the error goes away because we've
actually created that method and then
we'll make public void render and that's
what we're going to spend most of our
time at today so the random method is as
you can imagine gonna handle rendering
now we're going to dive into buffering
today and we're gonna take this slower
like is probably going to take us two to
three days so that means two or three
episodes maybe even four episodes to
actually finish this random method and
actually get a black box onto the screen
or a colored box whatever because I
really want you guys to to know the
process behind why this works and how
this works not just um what what code
you need to write so start off I'm just
gonna create a buffer strategy
essentially that's all I'm doing here
I'm creating a buffer strategy
now what is a buffer first of all and
again I know there's like I don't know a
lot of you sitting there being like oh
you kidding me this guy's gonna explain
what a buffer is chill okay I know that
some of you are very very smart and you
already know all this stuff and some of
you do not okay there's half of you
literally saying you know skip over the
boring stuff I already know it and then
there's the other half of of you going
dude this is great I'm learning so much
so just chill all right seriously
there's like this huge war going on on
reddit as to the speed that I have to
explain things so in other ways it's
better to explain everything and satisfy
everyone than to explain half the stuff
and only satisfy half of you so just
chill all right so what is a buffer a
buffer you can think of a buffer pretty
simply it's basically like a temporary
storage place all right so when we
calculate something we don't necessarily
need to actually apply that data
straight away we can just we've
calculated it great let's put it on to
like the ready list and then you know
when we actually need that data we can
look we can grab it so in other words
what we're saying is
we've rendered an image right now it's
already it's already done the image is
completely rented we're ready to put it
onto the screen but we don't need to yet
because we've rendered it but like we're
still on the previous frame we need we
need to actually store that that that
frame somewhere now the best way to
explain this is probably just to show
you guys now in comes paint.net and
those of you who have been long
long-term subscribers of mine probably
um you know see me use this all the time
in my 3d and programming serious because
Pantone edits it's really good for
explaining things
um I think of it this way right this is
our screen this is the computer monitor
and this is a it's embarrassing that's
just made it even worse doesn't matter
this is our desert computer screen right
so when we're rendering things we can't
actually render it live what you might
think is happening and again this is
happening very very fast remember
because most games to be actually really
smooth and playable Neron need to run it
at at least 30 frames per second if not
60 frames per second for more like
Twitter shooters like the first-person
shooters and stuff like that this is
happening like a lot of times this
happen a thirty to sixty times a second
minimum so it's happening very fast you
can't really say um the rendering going
on but we can't actually render it on on
to the screen because what happens is
when your computer renders things it
goes because what it goes like one by
one by the pixels it fills up every
pixel with the appropriate color um and
thus you know that makes up an image now
the problem the problem is that if we're
doing this live what you'll actually see
is a black screen and then you know
every pixel being updated live now
that's a problem because that results in
as you can imagine graphical issues
we're seeing an image being updated one
by one because the computers going going
ahead and being like alright this color
used to be blue now it's red let's
change that oh it's red now
and the problem with that is that you
know that's happening live in front of
our eyes and we don't want that to
happen we sort of wonder how I don't
want that to happen behind the scenes we
want to be able to calculate the color
of every pixel on our screen store it
somewhere you know as a buffer and then
you know when we're when we actually
advance to the next frame we pop that
image in and wow look at that we've
already got an array of pixel colors
worked out for us we just need to
actually display them and that's what
the graphics card does so in other words
what we're saying is that rendering
right okay first of all I don't know how
far you're probably screaming right now
what if I'm using the graphics card to
render all right this is gonna be pure
Java we're not gonna use OpenGL we're
not gonna use anything I will create a
series in the future using OpenGL just
not right now it takes a long time to
explain I don't have time right now
and I find that especially for people
who are new to game programming OpenGL
is a horrible way to go you want to
learn how to do it from scratch you want
to know how how computer graphics work
first and then you can dive into OpenGL
for hardware acceleration and to
actually get the graphics card to
process and render pixels not not in
this series so we're only using the
graphics card to actually display the
final image onto the screen not to
actually compute process calculate
render the actual images so just not do
we know yeah these episodes of getting
along or longer so I need to get back to
work quickly though all right
so essentially we don't want to have it
rendering live we want like I guess we
want like a yeah that's my help
essentially what we want is like we want
a temporary storage place where we can
work all this out and then suddenly
we'll be like alright this frames up
it's all we've already worked everything
out let's pop it into our screen now
it's ready it's computed its calculated
everything's fine now the thing is we
actually need to create a place for this
to be in our computer's memory right in
our RAM
we want to create an area called a
buffer strategy really to actually store
this thing we need to create a buffer
because essentially what a buffer is
again is it's a temporary place for
storage right a data buffer is it's it's
a region of physical memory which can
temporarily hold data while it's being
you know moved from one place to the
other so this will only be here for like
maybe one sixtieth of a second but it
needs somewhere to be and when you
create that that area so we can do that
simply by first of all drawing it on
Java's buffer strategy objects so buffer
strategy will Google just call it BS
drive trough or buffer strategy and then
we'll set that equal to simply get
buffer strategy now remember we're armed
and learn let's import of strategy
obviously okay now remember we're
actually extending canvas here so what
canvas comes as with its own pretty much
buffer strategy so all we need to do is
you simply retrieve the buffer strategy
of our canvas object which is our game
class now because it's a subclass of
canvas we need to retrieve that that
that data and simply apply you know the
current buffer strategy that we already
have because we're extending canvas we
just need to actually be able to
manipulate that now so we create an
object called BS so that we can actually
access the buffer strategy so we've
we've got the buffer strategy now like
the buffer strategy object I guess off
the canvas class now we need to actually
create it so we've we've got it we're
able to manipulate it we have to create
it now so the reason the thing is right
this is being this is being called
remember it's in a while running loop
this is being called this method like 60
times a second oh I'm sorry
more than 60 times a second as many
times per second as we possibly can
because it's in the render method we
don't want to create buffer strategies
every time we actually render that's no
literally we only need when we need to
do that once so what we can type isn't
is a simple if statement right really
simple if buffer strategy if BS if this
if this
object is equal to null then create
alpha strategy and then we put three in
the and the parameters and I'll explain
all this in a second and then we need to
return so what this is doing is it's
saying that if if the buffer strategy
current doesn't exist right because
buffer get buffer strategy is returning
null for some reason which means it is
returning nothing because get buff
strategy is equal to null
it hasn't been created yet and
No
yeah so you can see that what that does
is it returns a buff strategy used by
this component and its component being
the other canvas class so if if the
canvas class is returning null for the
buffer strategy because it hasn't been
created yet then we execute this code
which is we create a buffer strategy
with triple buffering and then we return
so in other words we get out of this
method now quickly create buffer
strategy creates a buffer strategy now
pretty pretty self-explanatory now the
three now the three the number inside
here it seems to be very important and
offer debate you pretty much always want
to have it three there are very few if
any circumstances where I would
recommend you leave it to for example
for just standard double buffering three
is the number to go now I'll explain my
reasoning for this first of all what we
want to do what we need to do is
multiple buffering right because with
with two
here essentially we're saying right so
there's this there's this area and then
there's this screen so we calculate here
and then we and then we we put it right
to the to the screen now if we put three
here what we're saying is that oh hang
on a minute
we've got another area we've got triple
buffering now what we've got is is like
another another like a midpoint almost
so in other words look at what can
happen is if our computer actually
manages to render a few images at once
for example I don't know if we have
multiple um CPU cores all that stuff if
we actually have time to start rendering
a third image we can actually store two
images in memory right because what
happens is we can actually you know if
we were using double buffering we would
actually our program would actually have
to wait until this this image is
displayed to the screen before we can
start rendering the next one now with
with triple buffering that's not the
case because what happens is there's two
back buffers and they can immediately
you know start drawing the next one
which basically gives us a speed
improvement because we can actually work
we can actually start work on
calculating the next frame before our
our backup frame is displayed so I'm not
gonna get too much into this but I guess
another way actually real quick
um let's go robust 6-under another way
real quick to say this is let's just say
we've got mumps they're black
and the default presets that's weird
okay what this is the screen I probably
showed the screen like green this is a
screen all right and then this is our
back buffer so what happens is this is
the image this is the image that's
displayed on the screen and this is our
back our back buffer it's like how um
you know our place to calculate the UM
the next frame now if you've got another
one what can happen is this is the image
currently being displayed and we've
already got to wedding in the background
so essentially instead of just waiting
we can instead of just having our
computer wait to display the next image
it can actually start work on the second
one so instead of just the the pros has
to go and completely idle for a few
milliseconds or even nanosecond and
we'll keep it in milliseconds instead of
the processor not doing anything for
nano seconds or milliseconds it can
actually start work on a third one
meaning that
that will be ready and you'll actually
be able to have two things ready so in
other words what we're doing by creating
a triple buffering strategy and I'll
just get out of that is again it's just
gonna be a speed improvement it's gonna
be as simple as that it's just gonna let
us let us have three buffers which
yeah which is just gonna help us out now
in case you guys are wondering well if
three buffers are so good why don't we
just go up to ten or four or something
there's there's pretty much no advantage
in doing that I'm just gonna tell you
it's right away that's not gonna
actually give you any real-world results
in which you have a much faster thing so
keep it at three that's obviously gonna
be simple that hope you guys I'm not
it's still something out of that and
tomorrow we'll we'll continue on with
this so I'm gonna go back to studying
right now is that was a lot of time I
just wasted well wouldn't say wasted but
um a lot of time I just spend so yeah
anyway I'll um I'll see you guys later
I'll see you guys tomorrow bye
[Music]
you
[Music]